why am i doing this video
why am i in this place today i woke up
and i thought to myself
i don't want it to sound like spying but
i just want you know what let me just go
to some youtubers
some people of influence some people
have really big subscriber base
and ask them no not actually ask them to
find
out have they posted a video about the
massacre that happened the terrorist
attack that happened that killed 50
innocent people who were worshipping and
injured 50 other
i went to a few youtubers who usually
have product placements sponsors
rarely talk about islam do you associate
themselves from being
you know an islamic personality and i'm
not talking about anyone specific
i'm talking in general i was just
searching i was thinking let's see
let's see because three four years ago a
saudi sister
got stabbed to death and i mentioned the
same issue then as well
and i'm not trying to play the high
horse here and you know i'm the dower
guy and i'm i'm not better than you
i don't know in the sight of allah you
might be more beloved to allah than me
but i found the need to do this video
and then i thought to myself in the
morning you know what just leave it man
at this time
you don't want to talk about that so i
was going to sister nasir pervin's
you can see that on the screen instagram
and she said
exactly the same thing and she was as
enraged as me
and i said this is a sign i said you
know what
spoke to a brother he said okay maybe
it's not the right time i said listen
let me ask my teacher let's consult with
our teachers
i say etc etc i explained it to him
he said ali go and do it now
and then i thought to myself yes this
needs to be done
50 people have been massacred dead
point-blank shot you have an
influence you have a following you have
a subscriber base allah is going to ask
me and you
i question my intentions every day i'm
not trying i'm trying to make
you guys understand again i'm not here
to play the high horse like i'm ali dawa
and we muhammad hijab and our salam team
we do great works and you don't we're
not saying that
today is a time when we come together
and we
talk about islamophobia tomorrow it's
going to be you
understand this you're not talking about
it and talking about this and that no
problem you can do whatever you like but
at least
at times of need say something about it
not just a tweet say something about it
do a youtube video
raise awareness i'm not having to go at
you for doing
pranks or this or that etc i'm not
saying that and there is some brothers
who do these pranks we differ with
but at least sometimes they touch upon
it so i'm not going to go with anyone
specifically when i mention certain
things
be hijab youtubers be it a blogger you
don't even have to be hijab whoever you
are you're a muslim
bring awareness to this i want to salute
eggboy i'm calling him egg boy i want to
salute him you know why
he went had the guts saw that somebody
is violating
the rights of dead people he went
got some eggs got through security
smashed the guy on the head with an egg
is that it no he was choked after that
the money that was raised for his legal
fees he's donating it to the victims
i salute you egg boy
i salute you my friend you did something
most of us
could never do i asked allah to guide
you
and it's a reminder if i come harsh i'm
sorry i am harsh i'm not gonna come and
say no it's passion i
am harsh i am angry i am annoyed
when are we going to do this when when
it comes to your door when it comes
knocking on your door when it comes and
attacks your sister your mother your
daughter your father
that's when you're gonna come and say
okay i need to do a youtube video now i
need to raise awareness now
is that what you're waiting for allah
says
you either no the person said in a
hadith you
either enjoying god or forbid evil or
allah will send down a calamity
even when your frustrated will not be
accepted from you
we are the greatest ummah the process
said if you see evil try to stop it with
your hand
if you cannot at least speak out against
it you have a massive following you guys
whoever it is you have big followings
and if you can't do it at least hate it
in your heart now i'm sure you hate it
in your heart and that is the lowest
part of iman
i'm not going to keep this video long i
ask allah to
accept the works that i do i'm not here
to put a high horse once again
i ask allah because i don't know if in
front of allah is going to be accepted
but
for you guys at least do something that
will help the ummah help people in
general man
let's learn from egg boy and i'm sorry
i'm going to do this
but i've got eggs here and i'm going to
be egging
those people of influence if they're
watching this i'm gonna be egging you
there you go that's that's for you
that's for you
and take this too
you